[Music]
[Applause]
are you winning son
the simple apocalypse is upon us how did
this happen
to understand we must go back in time
remember nice guys
i used to say i was a nice guy i used to
say i respect women
not anymore oh no no had things have
changed let's look and cringe at all
these
nice guys that are now just called
simpsons
you might as well is there a sim
subreddit by the way because this is
basically it isn't it
oh there is there's a sim police one
what the hell
those titties look suckable you're such
a [ __ ] loose
[Laughter]
nice sim police
stand aside someone is being respectful
towards women
someone shows attraction to women
stop that you simp and it can turn to
the dark side kill younglings
and betray the jedi order for a girl
making him
the galaxy's biggest soup he's a
paid for all her classes this semester
now she's talking about she ain't ready
for a relationship
laughing my ass off okay my dude i got
bad news for you you slim right there
that's a simp right there if i ever saw
one i want the sim police not the sim
valentine's day isn't just for
girlfriends and boyfriends
thank you for being my best friend
sophie i hope i made valentine's day
2019 special for you fedora
dang you really blew your check on a
girl who ain't even your girl
damn imagine a threesome with pokey and
valkyrie
bro imagine talking to girls oh
don't forget them
queen of sims why why is pokey queen of
sims
what is it about this girl that makes
y'all so
so [ __ ] crazy everyone loses their
mind it's kind of sad knowing that i'll
never get to
taste poke oh god skirt up panties down
and you're in
uh oh oh god these comments are
disgusting
she'll learn to like it oh you guys are
weird you guys are [ __ ] weird
disgusting you guys are
pathetic disgusting despicable
beyond all saving this isn't simping
these are coopers
jesus christ the simp subreddit
is not what i thought it was jesus
christ
don't look up the sims read it thought i
looked cute as hell today and my
boyfriend told me i look like
pinhead larry you hear that
the ships are coming drop that [ __ ]
you are
gorgeous he doesn't appreciate you
sweetheart
you need to leave him you gorgeous
i don't think you look like pinhead
larry at all
she is cute as hell and she needs to
dump his ass kick his ass then dump him
how could you ever disrespect queen
boyfriend makes a joke meme how could
you
leave him jesus christ
what in the world never say no to a guy
who had the courage to walk over and ask
you to dance in the first place
a song lasts approx three minutes
it's not that bad i wonder who wrote
this
[Laughter]
hey beautiful i don't mind that you have
a boyfriend said nudes
i'm a nice guy i am a feminist fine
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you're missing
oh that's so true when the five
doesn't work out and they get combined
fine you [ __ ]
you how dare you the girl i'm nice
and and
so what if you're only nice to get the
coochie
then you're not nice okay i am nice
beyond the coochie
and that's what sorry that's a weird
sentence i apologize
sorry that's a weird thing to say what's
a gesture or behavior that makes you
destroy someone
right away trust me i'm not like other
guys
i know how to treat a woman
i'm not like other guys i respect women
so flipping much i'm not like other
girls i think that's a subreddit too
it is they kind of match don't they hard
to swallow hating billy alex just
because she's popular makes you a
typical example
of not like other girls guess i'm not
like other girls huh
city girls be like we took the wrong
road country girls be like slide over
i'm gonna [ __ ] my what
excuse me other girls me
stop trying to be and i'm not like other
girls and get new underwear
shake my head disgusting
buy underwear pokemon source of revenue
there it is there you had it pokemon
queen upset literally she's everywhere
knife is funny after donating 4k being a
tier 3 sub i get banned from her channel
and subreddit
is that true yeah it's not even true
come on this is rude
i want to defend pokemon but i would be
a simple if i do it this is a problem
[ __ ] e girls simps valid criticism
hey pokey wanna get dinner or see a
movie sometime
nope i'm staying home as should you
that's the only reason because of kovid
hey women of tinder i'm 20 years old
have never had the attention of a real
woman before
figured i'd try my luck here never dated
cis head white canadian male avid gamer
pc master race
if you're looking for a man to treat you
like just because he's attractive
you're stupid for genuine
love and unwavering commitment to you
looking for real relationships for
preferably a traditional conservative
woman
one ask for nudes cause chivalry still
exists nigel what a god damn hero won't
ask for nudes
he will just expect them what a chad oh
god how do these people breed they don't
but how do they keep multiplying hey
beautiful
may god ignore you like you ignored my
greetings
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's a new one i like that one
nice guys to women before they get
rejected
oh dear oh dear gorgeous nice guy to
women after rejection you [ __ ] donkey
what did we do about the sim problem huh
nice guys
hey we're nice guys just looking for a
chat what are you doing you hurting
fat i just felt sorry for you huh
why you waste my five seconds god damn
it
you're really beautiful but you go and
date [ __ ] i'm dating them because i
like them not because you like them
oh [ __ ] wake up sip
wake up dude
[Music]
reasons why i lose girls i compliment
too much
i put in too much effort i
get jealous i care too
much it's such a
problem i am too empathetic of
a person no woman could possibly want me
see how you women are you choose juice
bags over normal guys who may
be even a little older in age but put us
down because we're the creeps you
deserve what you got because you choose
guys who dress and act certain way and
live a certain way you saw the red flags
but you always choose the bad boy give
me a break the video is called i'm a
heroine addict
oh for a moment i agree with him and
then the title is
okay all right moving on oh i'm very
sorry about that dear
okay i mean no harm to you like
seriously
i just wanted to know be better and
become good
friends that's all no thanks bye
i promise i will never hurt you please i
promise you okay
all right i'ma show you my pp i think i
wasted enough time here
what the [ __ ] is wrong with people
jesus christ
[Laughter]
see i've done i've done six nice things
for you
i've been nice to you a couple times you
know what that means
i have a big heart ass and bank account
how am i single james charles
simp question mark
i am the least simp of all the universe
i would never even think of a woman okay
the idea of being nice to a woman makes
me want to move to an
island and live like a hermit for the
rest of my life in solitude as
punishment
only when you find true love will it
shine blue
i know it's only our second date but uh
would you like to come home and do a
harry potter marathon
she she'll probably say i like you as a
friend
hey you saw my first messages with my
turn if you show him
that you're interested right away
instead of acting
like some little beta [ __ ] trying to
act like a nice guy hoping to win there
off because you're too much of a [ __ ]
to confess that you like someone and
then you carry up all this anger and
resentment towards that person
and then tell them to [ __ ] off just
because they don't see you that way
even though it's your fault entirely all
right
wake up simples tense
like reading some of these messages that
women get i'm almost
i almost get like what is this
what is this feeling oh god no
empathy for women oh god oh oh
now ow ah
never hey gorgeous wanna flip
it girl snow haha wow i even called you
gorgeous
i called you gorgeous where
is the sex come on come on
what is the nice girl said i forgot
about that what is the equivalent
of an female version they have to exist
babe i need you to change you need to do
better
babe i'll do better but you must do
better too
well if you can't accept me for the way
i am then you should leave the
relationship
sounds strange straight out of a tlc
relationship i love it
yes i was toxic but did i hit you okay
yes but did you die no okay
he unblocked me i called him told him to
unblock me
he unblocked then i blocked him we block
boys
boys don't block us i am so confused
about this subreddit
nice girls are there no nice girls is
that what this is proving i'm so
confused
me realizing that all of my guy friends
just look at me as a homie because i'm
not cute enough
for them to take me and they do exist
simp girls we need a word for it [ __ ]
it's not a photo editing software [ __ ] i
like it
[ __ ] i swear i'm a nice girl until you
do something that pisses me off then
that
will come out to play yeah me
is loyal is funny is ugly he's
supporting his
carrying loves you we'll prioritize the
my crush is ugly
nice i can put under the boobs too with
that one
i hit girls up at 1am and they will
think it's a booty called
i'm an intellectual let's meet uh yeah i
know it i knew it talk about the
universe
i can't stop thinking about quantum
physics
[ __ ] i don't want your ass i just want
to talk about
time travel and the possibility of the
infinite of space
i can't stop thinking about time
alternate realities the infinite
universe that is constantly expanding
i just can't stop it whenever i'm
killing noobs in fortnite
it's constantly on my mind it never ends
i know what he's saying though and these
things are interesting don't get me
wrong
man i'm on your side ninja at least it's
not ascent wait
is ninja married is ninja married
fortnight
ninja married fortnight that's okay all
right guys
hope you enjoyed episode subscribe more
videos
we're trying to reach 107 million
subscribers all right i got to sell you
stuff
today uh you like the hat check out the
hat
tambourine hat link in the description
also
if you want to go outside and not
looking like a simp
we got some protection right now
honestly it doesn't look great with a
beard
[Laughter]
but it's pretty cool get yours link in
the description
i see you gamers next time bye bye or
remember
i don't know do whatever you want i
don't care ah
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fart spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean